I missed this game cry I really don't I
miss these times where we play this game
remember watch out for the brofist oh he
got it
looks like someone knows how to play
this game wow that's really impressive
man goodness I miss this game so
remember this you have to walk up and
then jump wow that's so cool goodness
you really smoking me with that yellow
blanket of yours hey you want a blanket
see oh
come on cry yes right come on cry dad
don't actually jump oh yeah this is
secrets mmm I remember this okay alright
where's the secret oh yeah you get up
here but you gotta jump on each other oh
my god oh this is way harder than it
needs to be compared to what we could be
no really doing maybe we just want to
fall between those spikes instead I go
all the way to LA you know yeah that's
one kind of do this is like pure this
2014 content this is really this is OG
[ __ ] ain't nobody want this [ __ ] anymore
where we spent an hour trying to get
bloody trapline to working and we're
playing this rich you're so enthralled
with your platforming prowess I can't
look hey man I it looks like I'm the new
king huh I guess so man it's just that
he's got that blanket dude [ __ ] oh the
secret of the blanket it just weighed
you down that time that's the problem
oh man this is so [ __ ] I thought I
thought the game was more fun than I
remember we just old old and boring now
is that it it might be that it's it's
purely like you always want to remember
the good times and if you add all the
bad parts of those times
oh yeah yeah why do you forget the bad
part so I want to remember the bad parts
I feel like the bad parts are just
there's too many so you're trying to
like pick and choose Blanca March 13 oh
yeah there's a lot of bad parts right
here Oh like that had a huge connection
but I feel like there was something
possibly there if we really deal in a
proper shot but we were just too nervous
and young and stupid all right we're
just gonna go up oh [ __ ] I remember this
level we're gonna be here a while this
one is hard yeah while I remember Hank
anger problem did you sure easy he oh
[ __ ] you faster
[Music]
Wow Wow
hey for so thank the bullets for you
all right I'll tank the bullets go cray
I'm gonna do some crazy American ninja
[ __ ] here come on crazy [ __ ] I'm going
into ah I took a bullet pray come on
come on I got this okay - yeah I'll take
the bullets for you I swear
take the box you're not taking the
bullets [ __ ] okay on three no wait you
go first
I go right after come on see this is the
one we were on for sister one it's the
one this is like wait for me man wait
for you wait wait wait for you what I
[ __ ] saying you said you said wait
for me I'm waiting for you okay what I
say I said wait for me I'm waiting for
you I'm doing exactly we run through I'm
doing this you're not running through
specifically I thought it was simply
wait look look like why aren't you doing
that okay I think I think I got it oh
yeah I think I should watch this guy I
[Music]
[ __ ] school mr. Puri [ __ ] pirate god
damn bot is some og rage math boy
bringing it back okay yeah you do it
then you do it then you [ __ ] do I'm
coming wait for me there crying wait for
me
you got what you got dammit
bloody trap playing man okay I'll wait
for you I'm a good friend I like you oh
I'm [ __ ] wait I waited for you crap
wait for you buddy
we can do history I saw I lost you
blinky [ __ ] eyes I'm signalizing to
come save me
favorite game we got try mode we gotta
try really hard I'm I'm trying I don't
know what you're doing oh I've been just
[ __ ] around really I mean you only
try really try very hard
got it I got it alright I'm just gonna
let you do it do you do your boo
you know things for you cry okay okay
this one's for you buddy all right buddy
I'm so yeah boy dude my [ __ ] hamster
ate its young man it was hardcore not
geez dude dude don't you know that right
like hamsters eat their [ __ ] babies
if they're not like good babies oh dude
what this [ __ ] up hamsters are [ __ ]
hard
why don't humans do that I wish man like
well actually know some of you like the
umbilical cord it's really [ __ ] weird
oh it's not a good thing but I mean
apparently but it has so many nutrients
yeah well sort as a [ __ ] steak you
know like don't gotta eat the umbilical
cord where they eat it for the nutrients
understand I don't understand what kind
of nutrition are we talking about here
like the protein I could be a bit like
will I get x-men superpowers or is it
just like a lot of protein I think it's
just like you'll be like a really
hardcore hippie ah
this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm already here I got
you man you gotta work on that [ __ ] all
those people trying to be like yo Dawg
can i get a shoutout [ __ ] I got you
don't you [ __ ] worry every [ __ ]
jump so I've also come to realize
something what you called the brofist
right yeah that's not really
all-inclusive now is it what about the
southest there was a there was a swedish
article that came out but calling me
like a man at women hate her because I'm
excluding my female audience because of
the brofist really yeah
females can be bros too though I know
they can't they're not allowed like
people don't realize I do actually hate
women Oh
how do how do i time this jump alright
so got it you got it I thought it was
appropriate there yeah
[ __ ] I'm really glad ah really a thing
people do that much anymore what this
exactly what we're doing right now I
feel like it was just like it might kill
me more stress on top of everything else
abetting dude do this something the same
[ __ ] happy those levels yeah yeah
they do it's incredible people still
play it yeah I don't know what's worse
people making the levels or people
playing it I mean I guess it's probably
the people making the levels because
come on have some other [ __ ] idea by
now yeah I'm thinking about starting an
eSports team to this game yeah don't
[ __ ] my [ __ ] up now cry alright
don't stare [ __ ] my [ __ ] up we're good
you do so don't sink right now cry you
know what you should do to anything yeah
tell me you should quit youtube and sort
of band hell yeah what should I call it
God see that's the thing isn't gonna go
full vulgar or full innocent you know
full vulgar vulgar uh I can't stand this
[ __ ] anymore yeah I understand alright
we still play I don't know man instead
at this points like a Stockholm Syndrome
it's a good game it's a good game is it
though I like it okay
I mean you know as long as you having a
fun time with this that's all good
alright I want to stop